[Music]
shall we begin we are on a journey to
the future so what happens now something
extraordinary special revolution begins
with an idea that I don't ever say you
can't do something it's hard to fathom
how we got here checking in party of
nine eight adults one child for night
two the Groupon rate I'm the one who
asked about both the birthday cake and
the fire extinguisher
can you believe this can you feel it
there is only one war that masses all
face it together
dracarys
the planks is it on takes you from brisk
second time's the charm
exactly
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie the countdown
has begun
this is HBO's first teaser trailer for
the next season of Game of Thrones along
with its other programs they usually do
amalgam promos where they're like here's
all the stuff that's coming the first
half of the year so you may have heard
the news that they might actually have
to push the game of Thrones Season 8
release date by a couple months because
the visual effects so I'll explain
what's going on with that what the
timeline is we also found out when
they're going to be shooting the prequel
pilot for the long night TV series so
I'll talk about that at the end of the
video too if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the Game
of Thrones videos there's giveaway stuff
that I'll talk about at the end of the
video too so the big thing first you
probably noticed Peter Dinklage is in
this promo twice that's because he's
doing an HBO movie that they're
releasing called my dinner with Herve I
think that's how it's pronounced so if
you see him looking like this that's not
tyrion in a different costume that's him
in an HBO movie that has nothing to do
with Game of Thrones you probably also
notice the footage that they just
dropped for true detective season 3 with
marshal Ollie and Stephen Dorff they're
the new teams that they're gonna be
following so just a point of interest
the reason why there's not a Watchmen
promo during that because they're are
releasing Watchmen during 2019 but they
only just finished shooting the pilot
they picked it up for series so there's
no footage to show off so HBO just wants
to make sure that they're actually
shooting episodes before they tell
everyone that is coming in 2019 because
it means less pie in their face if they
have to announce that it's delayed
halfway through the year after already
having said that they're gonna be
releasing it during 2019 like that deal
with Game of Thrones the reason why
they're only just releasing this game of
Thrones promo now announcing it for 2019
it's just because they wanted to get
through enough of production to make
sure that it would be on time there
wouldn't be any other unforeseen
problems recently a lot of news
organizations were reporting that they
were gonna have to push the release date
out of April early May into June because
of an interview with the visual effects
department but that's not confirmed it's
just that one of the visual effects
houses that do a lot of dragon work and
they're doing a lot of big crowd shots
for the night army because obviously
they're gonna be two of the big final
battles of the series the visual effects
supervisor was saying that he doesn't
think that they're going to be eligible
for Emmys next year because the cutoff
is May 31st so that means that he's
expecting the visual effects to take
longer than
which would mean episodes would be
delayed by a couple weeks now there been
a couple people reporting that it's not
going to air till the second half of the
year that seems extreme what the visual
effects person was saying is that he's
not sure when they're gonna be finished
because the rate of progress changes
every week some weeks the work is more
intensive and it slows down some weeks
it's faster so he's just unable to
pinpoint an exact date for when they're
going to be done and they're just gonna
keep working until they're done it's not
like they're gonna release an episode
with a big battle with ps2 looking
graphics dragons fighting each other
with everything else looking really
fantastic he'd be ridiculous so he's
just saying that he's expecting them to
continue working night and day till May
2019 but here's the thing they don't
have to wait til every last visual
effect is done to start airing episodes
as long as they have effects done for
the first couple of episodes they can
actually start airing them and then by
the time they get ready to air the last
couple of episodes hopefully they will
have finished the rest of the work but
we're talking about like the really big
complex shots so like imagine how much
harder it was for them to do dragons
season to season by the time we got to
season four it really became intensive
it's the same situation when we got the
delay for season seven it was visual
effects but also then having to wait for
winter in real life where they film some
of these locations don't freak out about
it yet what's gonna happen is is
throughout the rest of the year they'll
continue to do interviews like this
where they'll update us on the status
now that they've started dropping promos
like this is the first of many promos
before the end of the year will actually
start seeing real completed footage
remember before season seven they waited
to announce the official release date
with that crazy block of ice stunt five
months before it actually dropped I
would still bet on a late May early June
release date for season eight meaning
they might wait to announce the official
release date to like February or March
it feels like they're gonna wait till
the last possible minute to tell us
what's going on just because they're not
sure how long it's gonna take visual
effects to be completed but they
finished shooting the season a while ago
there might be a couple pickups that
they do on green-screen behind the
scenes but right now it's all special
effects though good news is like if you
feel like that's a bummer they did
confirm that they're going to be
shooting the long night prequel series
or at least the pilot for it starting in
February which seems pretty early but
remember if they're gonna get 10
episodes of that out the year
after season eight years so like spring
2020 premiere date that means that they
need to work out all the kinks of the
pilot figure the characters out and
start shooting by the summer or like
late fall in order to get all those
episodes out I'm guessing that it won't
be quite as visually effects intense
right at the beginning so if you're
worried that it's not gonna be quite as
epic HBO did say that they were
committed to making it as big as the
Game of Thrones main series and they're
spending upwards of a hundred million
dollars per season on Game of Thrones so
if they're gonna spend that much money
on the prequel series is probably gonna
be pretty crazy I've already done a
couple videos about the plot that
they've talked about now obviously
there's gonna be a couple secrets that
they'll keep under the best but for the
most part we have a pretty good idea of
when it's taking place right as the long
night is beginning during the Age of
Heroes so we're talking ten thousand
years ago in the past they've shelved
all the other four pilots that they were
working on so either they felt like they
weren't strong enough or some of the
ideas would be duplicated in this long
night TV series like the rise of the
Valyrian freehold because that sort of
coincides with what's happening around
the long night history gets really
muddled when you go back beyond like
four or five thousand years and like I
said this will be between eight and ten
thousand years ago in the past so we'll
leave my other prequel videos that I've
done at the end of this but just leave
all your video requests in the comments
below a lot of this is really just
remixed footage from season seven but if
you remember HBO does compile a lot of
brand-new footage in these amalgam
promos so he ever wanted incentive to
just randomly watch HBO they drop promos
like this without warning so that's
what's gonna happen later this year when
we get our first footage we'll get some
random mish-mosh with a couple frames of
brand-new footage but it'll be jammed in
with a bunch of other stuff so you won't
notice it unless you're really keeping
your eyes peeled but we will start
seeing more actual season 8 footage
before the end of the year so everybody
get hyped up about that I'm still doing
that Game of Thrones 4k blu-ray giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
I'll name a new winner when I post new
Game of Thrones click here to learn more
about what's going on with the prequel
TV series and click here for my new
Cersei Lannister season 8 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you
tonight